hi everyone I am Tom Holland you might
recognize me as your friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man and I am here to
tell you that spidey's back for an
all-new Adventure in Spider-Man no way
home I know people say this a lot but I
mean it when I say that you're gonna see
things in this movie that you've never
ever seen before I'm talking about
pumpkin bombs sandstorm
the Multiverse which okay you might have
seen them before but I promise not like
this and not together also Peter Parker
is finally heading off to college and
the word is out so yeah everyone knows
that he is Spider-Man oh so throw your
fan theories out the window they're
probably not true or are they I get
ready to see one of the most ambitious
films we've ever made an incredible
story with lots of heart laughter
high-flying action mind-blowing effects
and some insane villains no way home is
the culmination of the homecoming
Trilogy and the start of a Multiverse of
possibilities
[Music]
my entire life got screwed up
could you make it so that Mysterio never
revealed my identity you ready
what just happened
well I shut that spell down we started
getting visitors looks like we got
competition from every universe
exclusively at movie theaters December
17th rated PG-13
where are we going I don't know your
house
hello Peter do I know you we started
getting some visitors from every
Universe this is all my fault
s we're gonna get through this
we're gonna get through it together
December 17th